Adonis is with us in Anchorage Alaska hi
Adonis how are you amazing how about
yourself better than I deserve what's up
awesome
well mr. Ramsey I just started listening
to you and follow you and I very much
appreciate you I just got my snowball or
my debt all consolidated and I found out
that I have a alone or the mother of my
children's truck it is for it's about
$4,800 and I found out that she's not
paying anything on it for about the past
eight or nine months okay stop a second
I'm a little bit confused here the
mother of your children is this your
ex-wife your ex-girlfriend girlfriend
okay so you're shacked up and she has
you had some babies and you put a truck
in her name and you put your name on the
loan yes sir and now y'all are split up
yes sir
okay you have a truck loan all right yes
okay that goes in your debt snowball yes
sir and how far behind is she on this
truck loan about nine months oh why have
they not repo'd it they don't know how
to find her
is that so in our custody agreement
because we have court you know or paper
this assess I can't repo the truck or do
anything to hinder her from the
transportation as she is responsible for
the truck so even though you weren't
married you have a court agreement yes
sir so I have 50% custody of my children
okay man you're paying child support no
sir no okay
all right the 50% says you can't
okay so what do you make a year right
now I'm currently unemployed I just lost
my job
Wow you need to write a country song
good lord
so what did you use to make about twenty
thousand a year sir okay doing one as
sales representative at a garden shop
gotcha okay all right so what are your
job prospects what do you think you're
gonna be making what are you looking for
I'm hoping to make around about at least
thirty yeah okay what I would love to be
able to do I'm guessing you have no
money right well so I've done a little
bit of things backwards
I had a Roth IRA set up so I had some
money set aside around about around
about like fifty five hundred or so
Joshua in that back that and no I don't
have any other and how much debt do you
have not counting the 4,800 on the truck
not counting the 48 would be leving
about twelve thousand okay so fifteen
thousand dollars changes your life yes
that's what gladly that's wonderful okay
and so you know in come in come in come
in come in come from 14 different
sources working six jobs is what we need
right yes you need to work like an
absolute maniac how old are you 23
I'm actually 33 30 okay all right cool
all right so I need to get you know
income solves a lot of your problems
because the bad news is you got a mess
the good news is it's not that big a
mess $15,000 changes your whole life and
so what we've got to do is just go what
if you
a job making 30 and you got another job
making 20 and you got another job making
10 you know and you were just working
all the time but buddy you'd be done
with all of this shortly because here's
what you can do with this car company
they can't find her and if you called
them up and said yeah I'm on this loan
but I'm unemployed ah you know he rode
$4,800 in nine months in the hole on
this truck the trucks probably not even
worth $4,800 right correct
yeah what's the truck worth yes yes I'd
say it about 5,000 with that oh you
think it's worth about what's owed on it
okay all right
so here's what I do I'd call him up and
offer him $2,000 to settle it so I've
done that really fast that's how I got
it down in the 47 81 because it was
7,000 okay about 7,000 Benson change
something about $7,500 and they said the
lowest they could get it was this 47 81
yeah tell me talk to your financial
counselor and he said that didn't work
for him because I'm your financial
counselor and it didn't work for me
awesome listen they're screwed they
can't find her to repo the truck the
truck's not even worth the 4,800 that
they're offering you so I would all from
2500 bucks and I'd cash out your 401 or
your Roth IRA and pay him if you can get
that but get it in writing get it in
writing and it's that they give you the
title they give you the title and then
you hand it to your ex okay that's what
I initially had told them that I would I
was really going to try to take care of
it but I do have about two thousand
dollars coming in so I was going to see
if I could charge not coming see exactly
what you said we're saying where's that
coming from
I had a check so I did I pretty much in
doing exactly what you're saying I did
cash out one of my
I Ras okay and so I I had the the check
coming in and it just got here but so
when I had talked to the people to get
the truck out of repossession yeah cuz
she has to transport my kids yeah I know
I got this I got that but they can't
find her what they Kenny fighting as
they can't find her this is Alaska it's
a wild wild west right yeah yeah they're
never gonna find her they don't know
where to look and you're not gonna turn
her in either so you know she's taking
care of your kids so you're gonna you're
gonna settle this for 2000 2500 bucks
something like that cash and you're
gonna get an in writing from them before
you give them any money and then you get
the title when you take them the money
it's that simple and then this is over
and you hand her the title and this part
of your crisis is over with and then you
continue with your income crisis and
your career crisis and you turn those
things around and you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be alright you got a game
plan here I do not tell people to cash
out retirement accounts except to avoid
bankruptcy and foreclosure and you're on
the edge of bankruptcy with this
repossession breathing down your neck so
on to stop a repossession I'll catch
this out in this setting it's not
something I normally tell people to do
by the way but your back is against the
wall here and this is a way to get this
get a deal on this and get rid of it get
rid of this problem all in one fell
swoop but you're gonna have to negotiate
harder 4,800 is not a deal it's not a
good deal
so let me talk to your financial coach
and he said there's no way that's a good
deal that all you gots 2,500 that's all
you can do if they want to take that
they can take that and they'll be this
will be off their books they haven't
gotten the payment in nine months and
they can't find the collateral
they're so screwed you totally hold all
the cards of this Kotoko table here you
hold all the cards they got nothing in
their hand and so that then and yet
they're posturing all over the place and
bluffing
so yeah just settle it settle it that's
what you need to do good question man
and if I can help you further Adonis you
call me again I'll walk with you through
this but you got to get your income
going man a bunch a bunch of bunch of a
bunch of income and new life choices
lots of better life choices going
forward
Wow life on the radio it's called the
Dave Ramsey show